Jason do you remember when you came to
Los Angeles and what your expectations
were I do I remember coming to Los
Angeles and thinking that it was like
this magical kingdom of Hollywood and I
had to figure out a way my whole goal in
coming here was how do I get inside this
kingdom and figure out how to you know
how this whole how it works you know I
was always intrigued growing up in a
small town in Pennsylvania
I was a I'm sure a lot of people when
you look at Hollywood from a distance
you're like there's something to that
but I just don't get it and I always had
this thought on my mind it was a it was
this block right where I think about
Hollywood and I was like how do you work
in Hollywood how do you make this happen
and so that was that's what was
intriguing so when I got here my
expectation was to figure out some way
to get on the inside did you go to
school
in Pennsylvania yeah I went to a small
state school in Pennsylvania I started
out as a biology major and then I was a
psychology major for a time and then one
night I saw one of the stage plays that
the theatre department had and I was
like oh I want to get involved in that
so I ended up doing some theater for
awhile and then my senior year of
college I saw there was a flyer going
around that said if you want to make a
movie come take this class so I was like
that's interesting I want to make a
movie so I ended up I took this class
during my summer in college where we all
came up with a couple thousand dollars
threw it in a pile and made our first
16-millimeter film and I ended up
co-directing that and writing it so
there's a pretty big deal at the time
and frankly I thought it was the most
brilliant movie ever but it wasn't the
next clockwork more interesting yeah I
thought it was I thought it was the next
Clockwork Orange right yeah I Stanley
Kubrick and I felt that way I felt like
because this was a time when when
Quentin Tarantino Robert Rodriguez and
like all those guys were making a name
for themselves and Kevin Smith and all
it was like oh I want to I want to do
that - it was really intriguing so you
ended up being a theater major that's
all right yeah yeah
and I graduated with with a degree that
I haven't really utilized at all since
graduating with a small exception is one
thing about the theater led me to
filmmaking and I wanted to direct movies
and continue what I what I'd been doing
and I ended up I went to New York City
after college and worked alongside an
independent producer where we made quite
a few independent what would be
considered low-budget movies and it was
just a great time and I learned a lot
during that
you